hello everyone and welcome to episode 5
of podly the official peacemaker
companion podcast brought to you by hbo
max and dc
did you think economos was ever going to
save the day i bet you didn't but he
does i promise with a chainsaw and we
also have economos himself steve agee is
here and we're gonna interview him and
talk to him vibe with him chat with him
and yeah you're not gonna want to miss
this let's check it out why is there a
bald eagle in your car that's equal
eagerly is your pet eagle yeah
is your dog named doggy
all right do you have a daughter named
daughtery
[Applause]
how's it going i'm miffy waddy way and
i'm your other host fiona nova and this
is probably the official peacemaker
podcast from hbo max and dc and we're
going to be talking about episode five
today it's it's a it's a spicy one oh
yeah what was what do you what was your
favorite part of episode five uh maybe
seeing a gorilla getting a job that was
that was also my favorite part
oh yeah i mean yeah
i mean let's get into it yeah
[Music]
you know it starts off with uh that real
sad breakfast that he was putting
together which consisted of an egg like
tobasco sauce sriracha or like whatever
i don't even know what it was and then
pepper
in a cup that is low carb so it is low
carb but he housed it yeah he sucked
that down and then he also kind of gave
um gosh yeah a little yeah
a little bit of that juice yeah we're
kind of learning that he he kept gotham
he kept off and it's taking care of him
and has taken care of him you know could
not kill this alien and decided to keep
it yeah so that's wild as a pet yeah
interesting
and adebayo
having a little trouble at home yeah i
mean i i bet it could be tough you know
to be like going into espionage as well
as trying to keep a a steady
relationship together i also just don't
think adebayo really knew what she was
getting herself into no not at all not
at all so i think it's really taking a
toll on her just mentally as well as
obviously the relationship yeah you know
she was thinking it was going to be this
desk job
easy simple but like they ended up
breaking down that they needed to go to
this uh this factory and that there they
learn about like butterflies how they
work and this amber fluid that they need
to survive yeah so they have this amber
fluid that um they yeah like yeah they
just need that to survive it's
essentially their food so um we're
getting a little by little we're getting
more information about the butterflies
what they are
yeah the fact that they need to eat and
that's usually that and that also
answers why we kept seeing them like
what is it like a a tongue of some kind
like their mouth
they're just sucking up this fluid and
you have
peacemaker being meena economos and we
have the explosion of it's the fact that
he framed his dad and he wished he could
have framed someone else oh can you i
know it's a it's it's upsetting but i'm
i'm team economo yeah no i'm with him i
don't really care
extreme racist yeah go ahead lock it
yeah you can lock him up i don't really
care i have no empathy whatsoever but
like we can kind of see sophie and larry
not letting it go not letting it go
don't let it go kind of well i think
their goal is they want to get
peacemaker to jail that's why they're
okay with letting his father go yeah but
i'm like i don't think they know the
full story yeah they don't know the full
story they don't know what they just
said
and now
you have sophie who's a little like
suspicious of the whole process and she
asks for uh you know uh
these these screenshots too right so
that she had she can do her own
kind of verification which jeff pointed
out was against the rules like oh oh you
you're supposed to be so good but you
breaking the rules to get those white
supremacists out of jail why are you
trying so hard to get him out gotta get
the right right you have to get the
right one but then this leads to maybe
one of the i think the better moments of
this of this show probably is this van
ride that they go through and they're
kind of bonding oh yeah head banging
find out that economos has the tattoo
and we're starting to see peacemakers
start to warm up to economos
after all this you know [ __ ] that he was
giving him he's like wait we like the
same bands i guess we'll be friends
right yeah
and to protect peacemaker from
you know sophie and and larry being on
his tail mirn gets his inside man in
princeton match the witnesses
immediately snitch i mean you know you
know the husband wanted to snitch
immediately because he was already mad
yeah yeah yeah exactly so we got a man
on the inside
there's it feels like there's just so
many characters in play right now that
like things can absolutely go wrong oh
yeah you know when you say like there's
too many cooks in the kitchen i feel
like that's right now what's happening
the cooks the kicks are in and they're
and they're cooking and i don't know if
it's gonna be a good meal oh yeah but
it'll be something
yeah something but speaking of meals
they went to the factory they did which
okay that scene of entering into the
factory and we see more of the power of
the helmet because i feel like we
haven't been able to see too much of the
the helmet power but this is just
another power he has there's another
helmet that has x-ray yeah who knows
well he came in blasted so i started
blasting yeah yeah yeah he came in blast
and adebayo's like shook she's like boy
what the hell are you doing and it's
like well i know they're butterflies
because i can see through them i see the
butterfly in their brain
what the [ __ ] x-ray vision i can see in
their brains
[ __ ]
you didn't think to give me some sort of
signal the signal was i shot her head
off you said you were gonna be chill
do i not look chill to you right now
so they're going in it's going hard they
they get to the the the center
everyone's running in and they almost
they start moving zombie ask they are
essentially zombies because they're like
they're being controlled by a parasite
in some way right yeah but the parasite
you know usually is really intelligent
but
you know the pads yeah yeah yeah they
and they're banging down they're banging
down well yeah cause they're uh harcourt
and vigilante are now trapped in a room
yeah they're trapped in a room fighting
a a
gorilla that is infected by a butterfly
which not new information it can i guess
take over anything that has a brain or
because gorillas are cousins or are
similar to humans right
we don't have the time but it's also and
if it is a brain why would the butterfly
want to take over let's say a dog's
brain i feel like yeah gorilla is a
great choice if you have to take over
any animal you have all that strength
it's strength it's strength power yeah
but that ape uh didn't stand a chance
against the chainsaw the chainsaw
chainsaw that economos came in with
saving the day because vigilance he
wanted to be the the chainsaw guy at the
beginning
he begged to bring it in
he said no there's no way they would
need it no and sure enough they needed
sure enough they needed it and economos
he saved the day yeah i told you guys i
was gonna save the day i told you and
then also this awesome scene
of just peacemaker being again like a
lovable idiot like i think he's just
like he's like st you're like oh this
guy's dumb but also he makes sense yeah
like he's right he's dumb but he makes
so much but it makes so much sense so he
straps a grenade onto a russian tank
essentially yeah and just throws it into
a crowd of butterflies and it explodes
yeah explodes big
and uh and my favorite moment of after
that was leota is like
why did why didn't you tell me to run he
was like i have to tell you to run yeah
that was the best that was the first
time peacemaker said something that i
was a hundred percent on board with
awesome you would tell someone to run
like hey be careful i'm about to throw
this you ain't gonna tell me no it's a
grenade and you saw me you were right
there when i threw it we both saw me
throw it i think that was great yeah but
then yeah we get that great moment with
them in the van all together they had a
great mission they feel good and that is
when uh we get that picture snap
and uh you know everyone's feeling good
it feels like a team yeah
until the team leota specifically puts
on that helmet and sees that burn burns
a butterfly we known all this time
now she knows i think that was like a
great cliffhanger yeah for the next
episode what's going to happen i was
going to answer all the questions about
mern being a butterfly because what does
this mean
we're about to find out we have to talk
about after this great
beautiful moment
everyone's feeling they're drinking a
beer and and i was surprised leota went
back to the trailer to dress
i'm team both of them okay but i i i do
i feel bad for leota because i feel like
she's under a lot of pressure from a
mother like amanda waller okay as well
as trying to just be a good a good
person she she has to go there put the
diary under there then get home in time
to pull the chicken out the freezer
and also are you really gonna disappoint
your mother when she's amanda waller
that's what i'm saying that's why she's
terrified that's why she dropped it as
an adult she did it as an adult she
probably still gets the chicken out the
freezer for a month absolutely she put
it in there then went back home yeah
just like you said every black fan
watching right now like it's kind of
shook because they're like did i
did i do i forget did i forget yeah well
i mean hey we've got steve agee oh yeah
and we really want to talk to him about
just being economos and his badass
moment yeah yeah and with the chainsaw
i'm gonna dial in and see what he has to
say all right
[Music]
okay we are joined by the wonderful
steve agee who plays economos and
peacemaker how you doing and where's the
beard oh don't get me started on that
beard i uh i'm doing great first of all
the beard
the second they said cut on my last day
of shooting the beard was shaved off in
the trailer it was a real point of
contention with with that that i had to
start growing that months before we
started shooting so the beard is gone
happily
and i'm doing great
all right well let's jump into the first
question so peacemaker has
a different strata of over over the top
characters and how do you enjoy playing
off both goofs like peacemaker and
vigilante and then more straight
characters like harcourt or mern it's
great and it makes the job a lot easier
i mean you can't have you couldn't have
an ensemble cast of characters that were
as insane as like say vigilante like it
would just it would be like having a
bunch of rabbit raccoons and a sack it
would just i don't think it would work
you need
straight men you know like uh
like jen and chuck woody uh
to help kind of ground things and um
yeah it it makes it a lot easier i mean
james writes for both both sides of the
scale um so well yeah wow yeah and yeah
it's i'll say y'all perform for both
sides of the scale right
luckily yeah we get to do you know i get
to be goofy i get i get my weird moments
but uh i get my serious moments too
which is for a character actor like
myself who's you know usually i have
recurring parts on shows where i walk in
at the end of the scene and i'm just
like duh this cake's good and that's
that's been like my range for like 15
years and thank god i have someone like
james to like actually write
actual human stuff for me to say and do
yeah yeah
i mean yeah if i i'm gonna take two
seconds to stand on the comedy soapbox
and be like yeah you know i've we've all
sat through an la acting class and
they're like yeah the comedy guys get
drama better than drama guys get comedy
because the pacing and comedic timing is
very similar to the pacing and dramatic
stuff there's definitely an art to art
to comedy and the art really revolves
you know a lot around timing and yeah i
gotta say though when i read these
scripts i was
super jealous of vigilante
this is the best character on the show
this is
that is somebody's dream come true that
is an amazing character that he wrote oh
yeah it's so fun and you're just seeing
the levels i i felt the same way but you
were talking about comedy and you come
from a comedy background so how has it
been transitioning into more action and
violence in the dc universe it hasn't
been that difficult i mean
for someone who's as
massive
out of shape and overweight as i am i
mean the difficult part is just like
running
there's a scene later on in the series
where i'm running and it was just like
jesus christ james i don't know if i can
do
it's like can we have for the wide shot
my stunt guy do this and they're like
jeez okay yeah and it's like that part
is hard the acting stuff is okay
and also clearly anyone who's with us at
this point knows that this show is not
straight action drama it's there is like
a huge amount of comedy in this which
really makes it a little more uh
comfortable for me i know it was super
exciting especially because before i
jumped back in i rewatched the suicide
squad and it was fun to see that we get
some more some more of the ag the ag
magic i call it happy for me too i mean
economist in the
suicide squad is
you know he's just that
guy you see occasionally and there's
really no backstory there's no arc for
folks like me or uh jen holland
and so it was cool to do eight episodes
of a show where you can see our
characters actually
grow okay so in this episode we have the
scene where john cena is just kind of
just naming celebrities at rapid speed
uh but you never got a chance to so i'm
gonna ask you to name as many random
celebrities as you can in 15 seconds
are you gonna start the timing when i
say the first one yeah i'ma just do the
fingers ready go jason schwartzman judy
dame judy dench sorry um ken jong
tim blake nelson
judd nelson
nelson mandela
humphrey bogart jack black uh oh that's
that's
up
well yeah when you're like under the gun
it makes it a lot harder you know
everyone's favorite nelson
that's i mean he's a poster on
everyone's wall he's a celebrity sure
yeah yeah i know he's definitely been on
a on a
cover of tiger beat you know is this the
episode where cena's just naming
celebrities
that's where it's from
why'd you put him there you fat [ __ ]
because i couldn't think of anybody what
about ariana grande or drake what brad
pitt or payne stewart or doug the pug
khloe kardashian the red tiger from
voltron fran tarkinton joe montana joe
montagna eddie murphy
michael jordan michael b jordan bts
eugene levy [ __ ] dude john lovitz shut
the [ __ ] up and listen man i'm giving
you a list of people you could have done
danny devito will ferrell howard stern
baba bowie robin ophelia quivers alice
cooper ozzy osbourne sharon osbourne
bill cosby he just got out he's got time
on his hands amy winehouse dude amy
winehouse is [ __ ] dead optimus prime
shipwreck cobra commander the [ __ ]
[ __ ] from riverdale
all right next time i [ __ ] have to
frame somebody it'll be one of all those
[ __ ] thousands of people you just
mentioned yeah tell that to my dad
peacemaker shut the [ __ ] up that was
hard to keep a straight face on set
while he was doing that he was
improvising quite a bit right because he
was improvising all of that yeah oh wow
he was
i think the the original line was like
why don't you frame like my res miley cy
it was like two people and then james
was like just keep going john and so he
started and then
it was like half an hour of us sitting
there while james like keep going do it
again another more more celebrity faster
it was it was impressive it was really
impressive i i really wish they would
post that whole role of him naming
celebrities as like a bonus feature or
something oh my gosh they they have to
that would that was so funny
it was amazing he was great okay this is
my favorite question do you want a clip
of you killing a gorilla with a chainsaw
played at your in memoriam someday i
would not mind that at all i
that was so satisfying to do i can't it
sounds disturbing to say that that was
satisfying but i read through all the
scripts at once and um
when i got to that part it was it was
all bets were off i was like literally
this is the moment i'm looking forward
to in the shoot so it was
and this was what five episodes in so it
was like i had to wait like months until
we got to it i was just like uh yeah
that was great what you did cena but um
i'm gonna kill a gorilla in episode five
so yeah i i do think in the eventual
ranking of kills in this show that's
gonna be a top ten for sure and it's a
super monster grill it's not like i
broke into a zoo and
chainsaw to gorilla it's
it's it's an earned kill yeah yeah you
didn't you didn't go after harambe too
you're like no no this is this was
earned yeah it was an evil gorilla not
to be trusted uh you did what happened
all you activists it was completely cgi
so calm down i was literally
chainsawing a
a giant board in front of me so you're
all good then you're like covered in
blood which i've i've done a few like uh
shoots where you're covered in blood and
that's always
cool for the first two seconds and then
cold for the rest it's
you're reading it you're like oh my god
i'm gonna be drenched in blood this is
gonna look so cool
and then it starts to dry
and gets sticky and it's really sticky
and anything you touch is then just
covered in blood
this was like halfway through shooting
the episode
and it's like oh my god i have to get
put into this blood every day now for
the next week just to sit in the office
and be like yeah i killed the grill
yeah blood be careful what you wish for
blood is uh
it's it's gnarly all right the next
what's the biggest animal you think you
could beat in a fight if they were
controlled by an alien parasite i
honestly don't think i could kill
any animal if it was controlled by i am
scared
when i come home at night and there's
raccoons in my area if there's a raccoon
in my yard i'll sit in my car until it's
gone i'm
so afraid and that's smaller than a
that's the size of a cat
so it would have to be an animal smaller
than a cat like maybe a mouse but even
then i'd be like
it might give me rabies
i i
i would rather fight a hundred infants
than
one small mouse so my answer for this
would be like i think i can fight up to
a coyote
if it was wow yeah i couldn't i'm
i'm afraid of every animal i
i think if animals realized how scared
we were of them
they would rule us like horses oh are
you kidding me horses are okay with us
jumping on their back if a horse knew
how scared
humans were of them they would just be
kicking us and being like no get away
from me go plow your own field idiot
every animal to me is scary
so your answer is
there's no animal that i think i could
be in a fight my answer is whatever the
smallest animal is and even then it's
kind of iffy
it's kind of iffy if he
so peacemaker has a disgusting drink
called the peace train uh
what would your signature disgusting
cocktail recipe be when i was in
military school there was a drink i used
to make we called it a brown cow i don't
know if that's an actual the actual name
of it but it was
root beer in milk
it was half root beer half milk it was
delicious
it tasted like a root beer float it's
exactly a root beer float but it's the
ice cream is unfrozen and melted and it
sounds disgusting to me now like if i if
i drink too much dairy now it's like oh
yeah my sinuses are plugged up and i
have phlegm everywhere and uh but brown
cow okay brown cow yeah root beer and
milk all right well before we hop into
the eagle email i just want to you know
close out strong and ask uh what was
your favorite part about working on
peacemaker i mean
i feel like i would be lying if i didn't
say the catering
[Laughter]
to be perfectly honest the best part of
shooting this was
being around people we started shooting
this
almost
probably 10 or 11 months into the
pandemic
so i'm not married i don't have a
girlfriend so i was
by myself for the first half of the
pandemic it was great to just get to go
to a set and sit with john and jen and
danielle and chuck and and uh freddie
and robert i'm just naming the kids
but it was great to just hang out with
every there there's a scene uh in like
the first episode where we're all
sitting in a restaurant it was just
great to just sit there even though it
was like
you know
all fake like there's just extras and
people cameras around
it was like so nice to just sit at a
table
with these people and just shoot the
[ __ ] while we weren't actually filming
and uh
yeah i i gotta say hands down the best
part of doing this was
actually getting to be around people
well damn that's great
you want some kleenex
before we wrap up this interview of
course we're gonna have to take a
question from the eagle email
[Music]
all right well this comes from a user on
the dc community boards and their
question is what's the best item
available in the workplace vending
machine at argus headquarters with any
vending machine
it i go between two things i go between
just straight up regular
lace potato chips i imagine they would
have those at argus
yeah um or like for some reason a twix i
never eat twix unless i walk up to a
vending machine and it's like
huh i haven't had a twix since the last
time i was at a vending machine
i would say either lay's potato chips i
don't even know if i'm allowed to say
that it's a brand but or twix
well look thank you so much for stopping
by it was great anytime i hope we get to
do it again yeah me too uh
like i hope there's not like
you know you see like john boyega
sitting in this seat interviewing you
no no it's gotta be here that that'll be
in my my contracts from now on all right
all right mine tiffy yeah we yeah
well thank you so much you have a great
day you too see you around take care
well
that was a phenomenal conversation with
steve i mean you learned a lot about him
he went to military school which was i
just thought was a threat i didn't know
it was a real place
yeah and now
it's time for us
to give out that peace prize
peace prize it's time
[Music]
so this episode brought us a great scene
which was putting an explosive on
another explosive which was from the
brilliant minds of peacemaker it would
just make a bigger explosion so i think
i want to give that scene that specific
scene a death to peace award
what the hell is that it's a grenade i
tied to a russian tank shot why not just
the grenade grenade blows up like two
people how many people does this blow up
i don't know i invented it this morning
what
[Applause]
he was able to
do something incredibly bold and liquefy
a group of butterflies with this that
single russian tank shell see i like
that you say liquify i usually say turn
them to juice and liquefy is you say
turn them to juice yeah yeah like like
you know if you're playing a video game
and you do something like that i was
like yeah i just turned them into juice
man there's just one word for that
instead of saying turning them into
juice there's one word you say liquify
yeah yeah i just learned that right now
oh that's awesome
many things yeah yeah yeah the
peacemaker podcast yeah exactly you know
but you feel free if you want to use
turn them into juice yeah you know just
uh just
so okay fine turn them into juice
liquefy yeah do you agree i think that's
100
yeah because you know it was just kind
of fun to see
this
it was kind of like
this
this
invention quote unquote by peacemaker
and like the funniness of like grenade
only blows up like two people yeah
there's like ten of them yeah okay we
need we need a bigger explosive yeah and
i love that he had it packed and ready
because he says like i might need this i
know and he invented it that morning
yeah
good thing there were no bumps on that
van right over oh yeah yeah right that's
a good note that was in his back yeah
yeah just dangling around playing around
oh great yeah oh we love peacemaker yeah
we do love people we here love
peacemaker
on
the peacemaker oh absolutely yes we do
well now i think iffy that's all the
time we've got yeah yeah i just want to
say thanks for listening and watching
podly the official peacemaker podcast
that goes along with the show
that comes to you from hbo max and dc
now i want you to make sure that you're
subscribing so you're staying in the
loop knowing when the new episodes are
dropping so that you can not miss a
single thing and if you're looking for
some awesome merch check out
shop.dccomics.com for the latest drops
of peacemaker merch you don't want to
miss it and to stay in the loop of
everything dc in the comic world make
sure you get yourself a dc universe
infinite account so you have access to
all those comics maybe even read some
peacemaker comics and do not forget to
go ahead and follow us on instagram
facebook and twitter so you can stay in
the loop of everything we're talking
about and so you can share with us your
favorite scenes from the show
also you gotta make sure you stream
episodes of peacemaker and podley on the
hbo max app alright we'll see you next
time but until then
keep the peace yeah we're keeping the
peace